avec son centre ville densément peuplées
ces vols directs provenant d'asie et
l'important foyer d'infection de sya tôt
on aurait pu croire que vancouver aurait
été frappé de plein fouet par la coved
19 mai le bilan des nouvelles infections
reste bas on a aujourd'hui 45 nouveaux
cas de kobe 19 en colombie britannique
le nombre d'infections en colombie
britannique et cette fois moins élevé
qu'au québec et le nombre
d'hospitalisations par habitant est bien
plus bas qu'au québec et en ontario la
province de l'ouest a effectué un
dépistage efficace des tout premiers cas
des éclosions apparu dans des résidences
pour personnes âgées
je pense que une excellente
communication entre le département de
santé publique et le laboratoire qui
complète les évaluations pour la kobe 19
de telle sorte qu'on ne plus ciblées le
dépistage est de façon plus précoce que
d'autres de plus les semaines de relâche
ou de nombreux vacanciers ont été
exposés au virus à l'étranger avaient
lieu plus tard colombie-britannique le
12 mars dernier le premier ministre de
l'ontario d'oxford encourager encore les
ontariens à voyager alors qu'en colombie
britannique le même jour les autorités
la santé exhortait les résidents à ne
plus se déplacer les chinois de la
région de vancouver eux restent à la
maison depuis plusieurs mois leurs
centres commerciaux et leurs restaurants
ont vu une chute importante de leur
achalandage dès le mois de janvier
lorsque les membres des communautés
chinoises ont vu ce qui se passait à one
ils ont tout de suite compris qu'il
devrait adopter les mêmes mesures ici 10
e correspondant vancouvérois d'un
quotidien de hong kong
puisque les chinois représentent 30% de
la population de la région de vancouver
leur adoption précoce des mesures
d'éloignement physique a pu avoir un
impact significatif sur la transmission
du virus
déjà dans cette communauté dans une
tendance à la distance sociale
à l'utilisation de masques donc dans une
grande proportion de la population
ça al'air pu réduire le nombre de cas
qui qui ont été recensés la
colombie-britannique exige maintenant
que tous les voyageurs qui reviennent de
l'étranger fournissent aux autorités un
plan d'eau totalement si ce plan est
jugé inadéquat
les voyageurs seront mises en
quarantaine une nouvelle mesure qui
aidera la province à maintenir son
faible taux d'infection ici frédéric
zajac radio canada vancouver